- And that's why
you should never
stick your hand inside a whale.
(bell rings)
Before you leave,
I just wanna say
that one of you is flunking
the class this semester.
(student laughs)
Steve, in the interest
of privacy, it's you.
Wait, I meant to say, in
the interest of privacy,
I can't tell you who it is.
- I can't flunk this class,
my parents will ground me.
- Listen I do have a solution.
It sounds a little crazy.
- Crazy's good.
I sometimes pour
yogurt on my dog's ass.
- Why don't you try studying?
- Hm, studying.
Schoolwork.
Work hard, grades go up,
feel better about myself.
No.
- Well I do have
another solution,
but it involves doing
a couple of favors.
- I love doing favors.
I'm a favor guy.
You know, party favors,
I can come to your house
and do a personal favor.
(teacher laughs)
- Hoo, favors. (laughs)
Off with you, favors.
Favors!
- What're you doing?
- Uh, nothing.
Dismissed.
- I'm stuck.
- I'm Professor Rich,
expert in science.
These are my devoted students.
Together, with the
aid of harmless drugs,
we explore science's greatest
hypothetical questions.
(cheesy '80s music)
There are many things
that change the
chemicals in your brain.
Yes?
- Once I ate a snowflake.
- And?
- There has to be an and?
- The bottom line is,
that there are many foods that
affect our brain, like this.
Thank you Steve.
Let's apply this thought
to our hypothetical.
What if milk got you high?
- Oh.
- Yes.
No.
- Milk contains tryptophan,
an amino acid that
actually makes us sleepy.
- Awesome.
Give Mike a plus please.
- Yes!
- Wait a second.
Why is Steve doing all
this stuff for you?
Did you catch him
masturbating or something?
- Steve is a little bit
slow and lazy, okay?
So he's my new
teacher's assistant.
Introduce yourself.
- Hey assholes, it's me.
Don't mess around with
me or I'll sit on you.
(students snickering)
It's not funny!
- I don't feel high yet.
- No!
After popping a
ladle full of Xanax,
I decided to speak to an
expert who took milk seriously,
and, wore a hairnet.
So this is where
the milk is made.
- Correct.
- Okay.
And so, I'm reading this,
it says raw milk supply.
I'm assuming this is where
the raw milk supply comes in?
- Yes.
- How does milk make us
feel when we drink it?
Could it make you actually
high or intoxicated?
- I don't think it can
necessarily make you
high or intoxicated,
unless maybe it's um,
been out in a
field, or something,
underneath the sun, or
something like that.
There might be a
post-chemical reaction
to the body that way.
- What about him,
does he work here?
- Um.
Shoot, what is he still,
what're you still doing here?
- Class, it's experiment time,
and I've got glasses of
milk for each of you.
Please pick one up.
And drink.
There you go.
Got a little on you, chin.
What do you think?
- Tastes like rum.
- Well that's because it
is dark Cuban rum, yes.
The simulation worked.
Not only was I wasted,
but addicted as well.
I needed to get help.
What is it that makes something
more addictive than another?
- It's a combination of things.
So one is just the
rewarding properties of it,
just how it makes people feel.
If someone does
something with friends,
and it's related to hanging
out with those friends,
they're more likely
to keep doing it.
- What about milk for example?
Does that give you
some kind of euphoria?
- Uh, sugar can activate the
reward centers of the brain,
but I don't know if milk can.
- You've been kind of
skirting around the issue.
I'm gonna ask you definitively.
- Okay.
- Does milk get you high?
- No, people have been drinking
milk for a very long time.
We have a lot of data, both
anecdotal and scientific,
that shows that milk
definitely does not have any
mind-altering or,
(lullaby)
rewarding, effects.
- So then I wound up
eating stale Chik-fil-A
out of a dumpster
with no pants on.
- Wow, milk's cool.
- No, it is not.
Milk should be regulated.
Like cars or businesses,
or those weird pedicure places
where the fish eat your feet.
- Regulations, exactly.
Steve!
Dance.
(students laugh)
- Stop, stop!
Shut up!
Stop, shut up!
Steve?
Why are you demeaning
yourself like this?
- Because I'm
failing this class,
I have no other choice.
- This is a self-grading class.
We're all getting A pluses, man.
- Is that true?
- Well I may have
forgotten to mention it.
- No, I remember.
You specifically told
us not to tell Steve--
- Hey look, a rat.
Is he even being honest?
- [Milk Expert] It's
time to go, come on.